will smith uh slapped i was wondering
okay wait how long have we been
recording i was wondering how long it
was going to take us before someone
talked about ukraine no no will smith
yeah i was wondering whether or not we
make it then i had it planned yeah i was
literally in the back of my house i had
it planned that at the end if we didn't
talk about the will smith chris rock
thing that i was going to say
it's amazing this is the first
conversation to happen in uh in a long
time
it wasn't mentioned oh no thank you
it revealed some interesting things
about um
human beings impulse control and uh lack
thereof but um
you know
oh my goodness chris rock has a material
for the rest of his career yeah i think
he's he's not short on material but i do
see if i if i knew what i i wanted to
tweet if if i knew you're allowed to
just slap comedians my conversation with
tim dillon would have gone very
differently
people just being humans i
there's so much fascinating human nature
on display there
um it it's also in terms of it coming it
becoming a topic that a lot of people
are talking about versus the war in
ukraine for example is also fascinating
to watch like just these kind of news
cycles moving through and i think if i
may i sorry to interrupt but um
you know anytime we observe something
very limbic very emotional
you know we generally can empathize
somewhat
right uh we all know it's like to feel
angry we all know it's like to feel
ashamed we all know what's like to feel
shocked
images of war
are
for most people very hard to relate to
we see it it's you know the these images
and they're very
traumatic and and challenging to look at
at times and yet most people have no
idea what it feels like to be shot at or
what it feels like to have your home
destroyed or what it feels like to be
um
an aggressor in that way so it's very so
i think that people naturally orient
towards things that feel familiar to
them even though the circumstances are
different and people also forget they
look at these celebrities
it's just like looking at criticism of
will smith you forget that
they're human too
that's that's one of the most surprising
things for me having done this
podcast and met celebrities and stuff
like that
they're human
they're all human and that's inspiring
to me like some of these great folks
that have won nobel prizes and built
some cool things they're just human like
the rest of us well and if you look at
actors and actresses i mean there's some
amazing ones right and who also do well
in the outside life but their careers
were built on
the
business of
pretending to be other people yeah and
that's got to distort
maybe positively but also
just
let's be honest what it is that the
neuroplasticity there the changes in the
areas of the brain that represent
personality have to be quite different
for somebody who pretends to be lots of
different personalities and gets paid
for it you're working the reward system
into the system of self-identity and you
know you have to imagine that that can
really um
contort
somebody's neurology in ways that maybe
they are not as in maybe they are not in
touch with reality in the same way that
we are remember earlier we talked about
neurotic versus psychotic
you know they may be more borderline
in their kind of ground state than than
we think and so i'm actually impressed
anytime there's a celebrity who doesn't
have a messed up life yeah i'm like oh
wow you know finally somebody who's
managed to
you know maintain a some semblance at
least from the outside of normalcy so
first of all i can
empathize with the actions that will
smith did right they're not
i think they're kind of sh not kind of
they're just shitty
you should probably talk privately
man-to-man
uh not because otherwise it's like a
dramatic display
it's like it's almost like you are a
fake act you're acting well they're all
these questions right i mean obviously
it was
aggressive at some level there's this
question of whether or not it was
impulsive i think most people feel yes
there's a question there was the
protective nature of it because he was
doing it to you know in it apparently in
defense but then there's also the the
context
he lost touch with the context right um
whereas chris rock basically gets
um there there's the possible critique
that he went too far
that's gonna be in the eye of the
beholder um but then and depending on
how you view comedy and jokes but then
there's also the fact that he took that
slap and then just snapped right back so
much so that people thought maybe it was
fake yeah he also waited with his hands
behind his back that's just natural he
likes to stand like that i mean i okay
um the
i i gotta tell a little bit of a story
here to connect
um
to what chris rock did like i
i wish
what chris rock did in terms of just
taking this lab and keep going first of
all just props for somebody that's able
to maintain cool in that situation for
the most part actu i think i'd like
watched it once you only have to be
alive on this planet yeah i know too
it's hard to see it you can't avoid
seeing it i wish
at that afterwards
he would sort of say something loving
and kind
to will smith
and his wife
and then hit him real hard
lean into the joke see and but there i
think in hockey they call taking a
number of a friend who plays hockey and
there's this idea that like if someone
checks you really badly in one game
you don't go and check them again you
don't get into a fight but three games
later three games you like you blade
them in the shin yeah like you so what
the the ability to defer
and to handle it in whatever fashion one
feels is it probably also friends and
all those kinds of things that they
respect each other so he probably didn't
but there's a comedian instinct i saw
this
i was in an open mic
in uh here in texas i won't say where
there's many open mics you know we've
gone to a few of these these are yeah
yes no so there
there is more sort of um
rougher kind of
yeah you've been hanging out in like
west texas yeah
exactly austin's too tame for lex so
he's like head to west texas exactly
i put on a cowboy hat and instantly i
became a cobb webb and talking like a
cowboy and i mean i i belong out there
in the desert he's gone from eating
you know meat and athletic greens to
rattlesnakes you're right
exactly right no there was a open mic is
uh late at night and this i was one of
the only people in the audience there's
a
couple of drunk folks a few drunk folks
one of them was a couple
uh and
uh like bikers like uh with helmets and
so on a guy and a girl and then the
comedian
uh the open mic comedian
did a joke about people who wear helmets
i don't know if it was on purpose or not
but he did the joke and then the guy
about women who wear helmets
and the guy is this exact same situation
the guy stood up walked up to him there
was no slap it's so interesting because
this happened before the will smith
thing so he he walked up to the uh to
the comedian
and and said he like
uh
he
he i think he like pointed his finger
down and told him to stop or something
like that and then sat down this is an
audience of like six people right and
and uh at midnight around then there's
no nobody no security nothing in texas
in texas which implies oh then this guy
was the energy drunk but also a biker
and
has
what he felt his lady was now attacked
by the comedian right with his words
and this and the comedian was a kind of
out of shape
small guy
this was not threatening at all
and probably in trouble
and the comedian after he sat down he
looked a little bit scared
he paced back and forth
and then he did the joke again
wow
and i was sitting and i started i i
leaned back and i just did this like
because that is comedy and the guy was
ang getting angry and angry and he just
sat there
and and uh the community went on for a
couple more minutes and then did another
bad joke but another joke about how it's
just like he leaned into it
if you go to a small comedy club open
mic or otherwise
you're in the shooting gallery like
you're basically there
teed up as a pin
to get it
uh we went and saw andrew scholes in san
francisco in san francisco yeah it was
hilarious it was amazing i mean he's
just masterful in his ability to command
an audience you know and but i felt for
the people up front but you know no
sympathy either because you know you buy
tickets to sit up front
at a shoals show you know you're going
to get it but he was very loving yeah
and funny first of all he's funny the
funniness really helps you but the the
the ethic of the comedian is like that
fearlessness i what i really liked
this is like the the danger there's risk
to comedy and there's also consequences
have you watched that show the um what
is it the marvelous miss maisel show
it's really good um i watched a few of
them um guilty pleasure there uh she
plays a comic in the i think it's a mid
1960s in
in new york and um and there's a a
character that somewhat resembles lenny
bruce that's sort of meant to be lenny
bruce um and
they're always getting arrested and this
this kind of thing i think i learned
about it from joe anyway it's the
writing is great it's very funny um
but yeah comedy is designed to push
boundaries right and to get and to say
the thing that you know uh other people
aren't
feel they can't say not something in
science right science you're supposed to
etiquette is a big part of how you
communicate ideas it's about
constraining
communication this is something i mean i
confess on the podcast in the goals of
making it clear
uh
interesting surprising and actionable
you know you have to constrain the
amount and the style of information
otherwise it becomes something else
altogether
you